i'm in front of the cameras today
because i really need to talk in order
for me to start my healing process
for two weeks i i was not allowed to
defend myself because i was following a
procedure
where
the law
of the law
obligated me not to talk
until i was in front of the judge
and god this
claims were proven to be false but i'm
going to tell you the truth
it has been so painful it has been
devastating for me for my family for my
friends
i don't wish this upon anybody
to the person that was claiming
this
nonsense i
i wish him the best
and i wish he finds the help so he can
start a new life
filled with
love
and
truth
and joy
and he doesn't hurt anybody else
now
my priority is to heal
and how do i heal
with music i cannot wait to be back on
stage i cannot wait to be back in front
of the cameras
and
entertain which is what i do best
thank you to all of my friends thank you
to all the fans who always believed in
me
you have no idea the strength that you
gave me with every comment you wrote on
social media
i wish you
love and light and
here we come
with the same strength and passion
god bless you all